hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
February is almost here but with a new
month comes brand spanking new games to
get our teeth into and February 20 1901
the headlining title of the month is
indeed anthem a game designed to force
you to return
day after day month after month and
potentially year after year if you've
played destiny and to a lesser extent
the division you already know the basic
mechanics and that's essentially the
audience anthem is attempting to steal
away
utilizing a third-person perspective on
the battlefield let's sum it up in one
sentence a perpetual shared world looter
shooter with a promise of better weapons
designer gear and the brilliance of
flying around like Ironman around this
alien world
I played the VIP beta a few days ago and
I have to admit there's a great deal of
work to be done on the technical side
before it's full release away you can
see for yourself completely free is by
jumping in the open beta from February
the 1st to the 3rd I'd love to know your
thoughts anthems full release drops on
February 22nd on the ps4 Xbox one and PC
one week before anthem on February 15 is
another Far Cry title this time it's new
dawn in terms of mechanics new dawn
stays faithful to previous Far Cry
titles it's a first-person shooter with
action-adventure undertones new dawn
takes place on the same map as far cry 5
but after the nuclear war ended areas
you want new are now different as the
bombs reshaped the landscape and mother
nature took back other areas during the
17 years before new dawn starts your
character is customizable once again the
guns for hire system returns and there's
a new doggy to stand beside you I guess
the old one died in the nuclear blast
from Far Cry 5 we'll have to see if
Joseph seed returns but we do know the
main antagonists are the bandit twins
Mickey and Liu who look like upstanding
members of the community far cry new
dawn drops on February 15 on ps4 Xbox
and PC at the back end of January a game
sneaked out without a fanfare after
playing it I decided to put it on this
list the Hong Kong Massacre if you're a
fan of hotline Miami or any twin-stick
shooter for that matter or if you loved
Max Payne or if you admire Hong Kong
action movies this is an unmissable
title and the best thing of all it's a
quarter of the price of a typical full
game we play as a former cop seeking
vengeance for his partner who was killed
by the Triads from a top-down
perspective we can slow down time to
avoid enemy fire and dive and dodge like
cherry on fat in addition to each stage
are challenges to complete unlocking new
weapons overall it's bloody gray is
cheap and it's already out the trial
series returns in February trials rising
continues the racing game lineage and
more importantly keeps the ridiculous
physics breaking challenges coming
although the game looks like it's
three-dimensional
we're actually tethered to a 2d path so
we call this 2.5 D there's a few new
modes to look at in rising a local co-op
game named tandem bike in which two
people write the same motorbike please
don't punch your best friend in the face
when it inevitably goes wrong we can
also create courses in trials rising and
share them with the world
trails rising releases on February 26 on
ps4 switch Xbox and PC how about a
fighting game jump force hits ps4 PC and
Xbox this month using a variety of manga
titles jump Foss takes different
characters and sets them up to beat the
crap out of each other
who is the best fighter Naruto Luffy
whom I kidding Goku's here at its core
jock force is a three-on-three tag
battle and so far 39 characters spanning
16 manga series have been confirmed with
Fist of the North Star yu-gi-oh and
bleach represented to brand-spanking-new
characters are also created especially
for this game jump boss releases on
February 15 on ps4 Xbox one and PC have
you ever tried the God Eater games well
the third installment releases this
month on PC and is a console exclusive
on ps4 just like previous outings God
Eater remains a hack-and-slash
role-playing game in which we are tasked
to hunt down and murder eyes these
hulking great monsters known as the
paragon II our characters are equipped
with Akwesasne that transform into guns
on the battlefield to ramp up the action
in addition we can absorb energy from
the beasts to utilize special burst
moves and attacks and the icing on the
cake is that the entire game can be
played cooperatively between four
players the assault missions by the way
beat that by sub
hotting eight players simultaneously God
Eater three hits the Western market on
February 8 another game on its third
installment is Metro this time named
Metro Exodus a first-person shooter with
strong narrative elements based on the
novels by Dmitry Nichols are e4
pronouncing that so badly it's
reasonable to class exodus as a horror
title with stealth elements as the
post-apocalyptic wasteland that was once
Russia is now filled with mutated
creatures weapons in game are
handcrafted forcing us to scavenge for
loot and materials which is where the
linear path opens up into a sprawling
sandbox with a fully functioning
day/night cycle and weather system to
contend with Metro Exodus releases on
ps4 PC and Xbox one On February 15 how
about a racing game dirt rally 2.0
releases on February 26th and is
essentially the 13th title in the Colin
McRae series which was rebranded back in
2015 as you can already tell this is a
simulation racing game with as close to
real-world physics as possible which
means we can race at breakneck speeds
without risking our real-world necks the
game is backed by the FIA world
rallycross championship and takes cars
and tracks from that organisation the
key improvement from yesteryear is the
real-time changes in road and weather
conditions with rain wear-and-tear and
your general approach all affecting the
road surface especially grip and
traction grabbing it let us know in the
comments and finally the lego movie part
2 no I'm only kidding the occupation
completes our list this month this game
takes place over for real-time hours
inside a suspect government building
back in 1987 just before the game begins
a terrorist has killed 23 people but all
other details must be found in the game
instead of a health meter any wrongdoing
will be met with your for our play time
being reduced giving you less time to
achieve your goals and get to the bottom
of the story and of course there are
multiple ways to achieve each goal
giving the occupation replayability its
genuinely trying to do something
different and for that it deserves a
spot on this list so there we have it 9
new games to play in February 2019 when
you take your fancy or are you still
playing Resident Evil and Kingdom Hearts
from last month I imagine from
PlayStation grenades it's been a bloody
pleasure
[Music]